des pochettes de la décoration ou encore
des vêtements pour enfants tous les
objets que vous trouverez à capsules
market sont faits main autre
particularité ils sont renouvelés tous
les quinze jours on permet aux créateurs
d'avoir un espace restreint dont peu
cher pendant un durée une durée limitée
donc peu cher aussi pour eux donc c'est
pas un gros coup et ça leur permet en
fait de développer et de se faire
connaître
depuis son lancement la boutique a
accueilli 250 créateurs un concept qui
les séduit moi je suis jeune créatrice
je vend principalement sur internet est
donc là le fait d'être en boutique de
rencontres et de ses clients voilà c'est
une chance énorme qu'elle nous offre
moi je crée dans mon appartement donc
c'est vraiment une opportunité de
pouvoir le présenter au public
et puis voilà de rencontrer sa clientèle
de rencontrer d'autres créateurs en plus
des créations que vous pouvez trouver
ici capsule market propose également des
expositions carte de fidélité et carte
cadeaux seront bientôt proposés aux
clients
un an et demi après l'ouverture de cette
boutique le bilan est positif
on commence à voir une vraie clientèle
très fidèle et puis quelque chose de
très positif aussi pour nous c'est que
depuis maintenant six mois à peu près on
a des créateurs qui nous demande même de
venir exposer alors que jusqu'ici
c'était à nous d'aller chercher passé
énormément de temps sur les réseaux
sociaux des créateurs qui seront encore
plus nombreux à proposer leurs produits
pour 2018 les clients pourront découvrir
tous les quinze jours le travail d'une
vingtaine d'exposants